[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive in the next
half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the journalist and author rachel
shabby and the executive director of the
henry jackson society
alan mendoza um let's see there's alan
allen rachel's having some problems some
tech problems but we'll get her up as
soon as we can
um alan's here with us alan thank you
for joining us um
first let's have a look at what's on
some of the front pages
the observer has spoken to senior
officials in the food supply sector who
allege that the government has handled
the so-called pandemic
badly enough to make the situation
actively worse
the sunday people here's the problem of
mass pinging has also affected border
force staff
leading to substantial delays at
heathrow airport
although the delays at heathrow airport
might be the least of your worries if
you had cancelled holidays in france
planned this summer the mail
analyzes the quote fiasco surrounding
the prime minister's last minute
decision to enforce
quarantine on return from france even if
you're double vaccinated
while the star has fun at the expense of
people who use teeth whiteness which
have apparently been in short supply
because of widespread self-isolation
the sunday mirror understands the
government intends to press ahead with
vaccine passports at football stadiums
although clubs are reportedly worried
that restricting the number of attendees
could push them into financial
difficulties
the telegraph has the same story its
headline mentions the premier league but
if they're brought into effect the
admission policies would go as far
down the rankings as the bottom of
league two
scotland on sunday carries testimony
from hospitality workers who say
in the wake of lockdown their employers
aren't doing enough to keep them
safe from the dangers of kovid
the express says the prime minister
wants to give every victim
of crime access to a named police
officer who will handle their case
and be a point of contact
while according to there you go the
sunday times some private schools are
being accused
of attempting to give their pupils an
unfair advantage by
lobbying top universities to give them
places before their results are known
we are joined tonight as i was saying by
rachel shabby she's here she sorted out
her tech difficulties
and alan mendoza thank you so much um
for staying up and chatting to us
the pandemic continues i've heard it
called ping mageddon
as well um i don't know which one i
prefer i think ping mageddon
but good evening to you both let's start
with the observer um alan what do you
make of this food bosses saying that
ministers are
making supply chaos worse
well it's a difficult one isn't it it's
this whole pandemic has taken over the
the country's sensibilities
and you can see this in the food supply
uh conversation because
the government has seen obviously the
concerns about you know
shelves not being full in supermarkets
has tried to come up with a way
um of you know getting around that by um
excluding 10 000
from the whole uh self-isolation focus
if they do the lateral testing in that
way
but of course others are now saying but
you're doing this this is actually
causing more problems rather than less
you're
you're not linking through to the
supermarkets it's all very well to get
the
the the food on the uh at least to the
supermarkets but then we can't get them
onto the shelves because there's no
staff there so
in a sense it's it's a bit of a circular
argument we're going back to this whole
point
who should be self-isolating who or you
know who ought to be selfish think
should we be moving this
uh date line up from the 16th of august
and currently
we don't have many answers rachel what
do you think because it is difficult
isn't it to come up with some sort of
coherent list
at such short notice
well i'm i'm not saying it's not
difficult but that doesn't mean the
government hasn't
epically handled this in a chaotic
um unpredictable and disruptive way as
indeed
many in these food in these sectors
affected not least the food industry
have been saying as indeed whitehall
itself
has been saying and as for notice well
the government announced that it was
going to have this freedom day
uh months ago so it certainly had time
to anticipate
and predict this um a lot of people are
pinging because we have a lot of
infections in the population one in 75
people
has it so let's not forget that is that
is the source reason
but also um you know it it
it does make sense that the government
should have thought about this in a
joint joined up way particularly with
the food sector
uh so you can't just you know address
one bit of the chain and expect the rest
of it to be
okay clearly it won't be and it hasn't
and that's what the food sector is now
warning about but it is affecting
other industries as well not least the
hospitality sector where it's but worth
bearing in mind a big
chunk of uh sectors like hospitality
like food packing
um these frontline workers very young
people most of whom
have yet to be vaccinated or most
certainly double vaccinated
so again we're placing this population
at risk
because of just government bungling
essentially
alan do you agree with that well i
wouldn't say government bundling's the
appropriate term to you say you know all
the way through this we've been
wrestling with new situations
um dramatic changes occurring at any
time you know at one point we all
thought this would be the summer we
would all be free
and because we'd all be double
vaccinated at least well on the way and
then suddenly delta variant of course
takes over in that process
i think it's in it it's it's not fair to
you know to slight the government in
this way the reality is
they're very very difficult uh choices
to be made at every opportunity
and you know we are feeling our way
through
every new stage of this without data
without understanding properly
how to tackle it and the government's
you know making the choice to try and
keep as many people
safe as possible uh for as long as
possible in this whole process now
is it chaotic yes it is but to be honest
there's hardly been a stage of this
pandemic
in any country that hasn't been chaotic
in this way and once again because of
our situation here
having so many cases while still of
course having the vaccinations being
rolled out
um you know we're once again leading the
world in this kind of point because
nobody else is at the stage we're at
and in fact it's worth noting that you
look at some other countries they've
made very different choices um
at this point in time what we need to do
now is look at i think this date of
august 16th the one thing i'm not
i'm a bit confused about is why on that
date everything changes rather than now
yes maybe more people double vaccinated
them but still i'm a bit confused about
that aspect and maybe
that's something that we'll hear more
about from the government this week
um there's sunday people on the front of
their papers saying uh holiday border
farce airport travellers had to queue
for hours yesterday because of a border
force pandemic
um the sunday telegraph saying that it's
also affecting
the mets but bin men get a reprieve
rachel if you don't think that this is
what should have happened it's chaotic
they've bungled it what do you think
they should have done
i mean i think it's absolutely absurd um
borderline irresponsible to claim that
we don't have data or understanding
we've had 18 months of you know who and
leading scientists constantly providing
data
and understanding it's worth pointing
out that our government
has consistently ignored who advice
about how to deal with the pandemic
i.e it did not build a test trace uh
an isolate system that worked rather it
squandered 37 billion pounds
on that's not ignoring it is it i mean
they did build a test trace and isolate
system
they built a they sent it to the private
sector who did not know what they were
doing and which a
parliamentary select committee said had
no discernible effect whatsoever
so no they didn't ignore it instead they
used it as an opportunity to siphon off
37 billion pounds to private donors
um but also even measures like
um financially supporting people who
need to
self-isolate so that they are able to do
so just imagine if a chunk of that 37
billion
had instead been offered as assistance
to help people who need to self-isolate
what a difference that might have been
so i do think that along the way
there are definitely measurable tangible
things that the government could have
done
and ignored and it would be
irresponsible of us to pretend that
that's not the case
and go ahead i see you shaking your head
well
you know i've read an article which kind
of sums up why rachel's points here are
just a bit silly i'm sorry to say
because if you look at
if you look at the history of the test
trades program a lot of complaints at
the start oh it's not fit for purpose
it's not working
and now of course the complaints are
it's working too well we're all being
pinged it's all work everyone knows who
you know who's been in contact with in
this way
it's the only it's only program
unfortunately where it's slammed for not
working well and working too well in
this regard
the reality is that the program is
working very well as we say now
too well perhaps in terms of how that
kind of works and connects up
and looking back on it there will be
this whole inquest to look into
what happened over the course of the
pandemic and it's all pretty well for us
to sit here in our
you know tastefully created homes rachel
i do admire your bookcases some good
books on there
but um you know and make those points
the reality is
that's going to have to come out in a
full discussion in a full investigation
as to what happened 12 months ago 16
months ago
uh eight months ago in this crisis what
we have to look at is what's happening
now and that's what's most important um
but
it's interesting um rachel what you
mentioned it
the we spoke to jenny harris yesterday
who said we have this pandemic
because we have a pandemic do you feel
that the sense
uh well the the um the issue at heart
gets lost that people are getting pinged
because
they're coming into contact with people
who tested positive
and whether or not that you know they
have to self-isolate or they're going to
spread this virus bottom line
absolutely the reason people are getting
pinged is precisely as the scientists
are saying and by the way
it really doesn't matter what i in my
you know
home next to my bookcase thing it
doesn't matter at all what matters is
what the scientists are saying
and as you say the scientists are saying
the reason so many people are getting
pinged
uh is because one in 75 of in the
population
has covered so you know if i were to
take a bus
or to go on a train one in 75 people
there would have comforts of course
we're going to get pinged more
and that's the thing that we've lost
sight of now of course
as well the vaccine is having an effect
on that it is meaning that not all of
those
will translate into hospitalizations but
certainly
a high number of them are high enough
for the nhs to now be saying
look we need to rededicate some of our
um
emergency wards and intensive wards to
covid which means that they're not
um doing those other uh
vital medical treatments including
cancer
of which there is a huge backlog so
there is many
and varied and bad consequences
of the government having let the virus
rip
through the population now and having
decided
that that is acceptable there are
consequences to that and we need to
discuss
that alan do you think that there is um
an argument to be had
for if they were going to open
everything up on the 16th of august
that it should have coincided oops i'm
throwing my pen across the studio here
that they should have had you know not
this gap
if everyone doesn't have to self-isolate
from the 16th of august
why don't you just keep the social
restrictions in place until that day
well this is i think you know there's
there's confusion about this aspect of
it i think i think look we're working
towards a timetable
uh where um you know freedom day
so-called freedom day would occur and
you know the government has
had to make a difficult choice about
where it was going to draw the line
on these issues and i think what it's
done um
has been to look at the the link between
obviously vaccinations hospitalizations
and deaths
now rachel says that you know it's high
it's not high it's actually a very low
link as we know in the sense of
um if you compare this number of cases
with the hospitalizations yes there are
people being hospitalized and sadly
dying absolutely
but um it's nowhere near a fraction of
what was happening back in december
january
um and so the government felt able to
release you know the restrictions on
that basis and they're not wrong on that
side the science clearly shows
that the vaccination program has you
know kind of
weakened that link dramatically so from
that point of view
um it was right i think to uh loosen the
restrictions
because you've got to get a break yeah
sure but where we are now quickly is
basically i think
we have to i would actually move the
time of the restrictions forward
ending in terms of self-isolation saying
look we trusted the vaccine
let's keep on trusting the vaccine
that's where we should be going from now
okay um
right let's start with the sunday
express rachel what is this about
every every victim is to have a named
police officer so that sounds like it's
gonna work
um yeah i'm not really sure how
that's gonna work to be honest i'm not
sure it's particularly thought through
um that this is part of the pm's
uh tackling crime which obviously the
government likes to trump it about quite
often because that's uh
red meat to its base um although it
rarely does follow through
and in this case uh the prime minister
is saying
um you know experiencing crime is is
a horrible and traumatic experience of
course
and that uh victims of crime should have
access to a police officer
um like a direct line whether that's by
phone or by email so that they can have
uh one-to-one contact at a really tough
time
um adam what do you think i mean this is
one of his manifesto pledges isn't it
back in 2019 he's actually
writing in the sunday express
yeah i mean look i think rachel's i'm
getting the impression rachel's not a
fan of the government very
much um i think you know it's not red
meat to the base this is you know people
who've
suffered crime you know want to have
action about crime and sometimes are
worried about how
essentially that you know they get
through to the police
in a consistent and um
you know kind of repeated manner now
there are of course implementation
questions about this
um you have to look at how on earth
you're going to get a name police
officer in each place
to to be in contact with a victim of
crime but on the surface of it it's a
great idea
because what people will have is the
ability to speak to one person
follow it up with one person see their
case through and they will have that but
rather than being passed around
different nameless um faces in in
different places so
from that perspective i think it's to be
encouraged although as always the devil
will be in the detail
um now and i'm going to stay with you on
this one because you were particularly
excited about this story um as were lots
of people on twitter
please explain to us about this very
real
and damaging shortage on the front of
the star
well i think that this is the story of
the day basically
um it looks like we have a shortage of
teeth whitening kits uh in this country
and i've got to be honest
if you look at those uh you know kind of
celebs like the simon cowell in
particular
we are you know what will happen without
being dazzled when you turn on a tv
screen or look in a paper
i think we'll all i think we will all
you know kind of lose faith
in celebrity as a result of this rachel
does anyone know why we have a shortage
of these kits
very briefly has anyone read the actual
story i don't have page four or five i'd
like to know why there's a horse
on the front of that but i also i think
it's because apparently people have been
doing
self uh whitening uh at home in
you know in lockdown nothing else to do
yeah okay okay well let's end it on that